Hank, we had this big conversation about how you weren't gonna get me anything for my birthday,
because I didn't get you anything for your birthday, and then what should show up in our office but Nerd Fighters,
the actual original video game! I'm a very happy person  right now. Thank you.
I'd like to announce my retirement from writing and the fact that I am going to become a full ti- ahhh.
I may not be ready to become a full-time nerd fighters player
because as soon as I announced my retirement... I lost.
So Hank, good news and bad news. The bad news is that I'm now hundreds of miles away
from the AMAZING birthday present you got me, I- ahahahh!
The good news is that I'm back in Pittsburgh, on the set of the TFIOS movie.
So, I always thought that when they made movies - by the way, this is Ben Richardson, the cinematographer
of the movie - I always thought when they made movies and there's like seven different angles in a shot,
that it was seven different cameras, you know? But it turns out there''s just one very expensive camera
seven different times. [Ben:] Exactly. This was one of the great delights of my life,
was trying to explain this principle to my mom. The tricky thing is, if we had another camera right now,
for the shots that we just got, the cameras would be right there, in front of the car -  [John:] Yeah! Of course.
No, I realize that now, Ben! There's Deb. She does the [John tries to make snapping noise]. Action! [actual snapping noise]
One of the weird rules of making the movie is, we're not allowed to do anything until Deb hits the slate.
Like, I can't eat until.. [Deb:] Marker. [Snap]
And if I wanna go to the bathroom... [Deb:] Marker. [Snap]
By the way, I was just, like, 'why do all these cars have Indiana license plates?'
And then I remembered, because of the movie!
So, Hank, I always thought that making movies was super glamorous, but it turns out that
it's mostly just a construction site. However, there is one very glamorous facet to the moviemaking process:
I am referring, of course, the the porta-potties.
I mean, Hank, I've lived in apartments smaller than this porta-potty. It has both a toilet and a urinal.
It also smells great in here, by the way. It smells like angles and stardust.
I am serious. This is a FANCY porta-potty.
Also, there's free food. Including... Atomic Fireballs, did you see that, Josh?
[Josh:] I did. Should we have Nat... cut. Should we have Nat maybe eat this right before he kisses Monica for the first time?
I'm here, with Isaac and Alex. "Hello," Isaac, "Hey," and Alex. And they were just saying that I should...
I should just stand in for Ansel. I am Gus. [Alex:] I mean, he looks, older than you, actually.
[Isaac:] It's like the Olsen twins.
But of course most of my time on set is spent watching and listening,
although now with Nat Wolff making trouble in the background. Oh, Nat. I love you, too.
So, Hank, one of my favorite things about the movie so far is they cast real teen cancer survivors
for the support group, they're waving to you right now, in fact.
And I wanna thank all of them for being part of the movie, and also for sharing their experiences
with us, it's just been awesome to hang out with them. Mind if I send this to TMZ?
[Shailene:] Hello? Oh, hey, Sarah. What's up?
[John:] Can I tell you what's funniest about that? I turned the camera away when you answered the phone
because you're such a good actress that I thought you were really on the phone.
[laughing] That's just pure talent.
I'm here with Ansel Elgort, who's playing Gus in The Fault in Our Stars movie and has a blue tongue,
uhm, we're gonna do, like, a quick Question Tuesday and then people can submit questions
and then maybe we'll do another Question Tuesday in the future with real questions.
But the question I get the most often is 'have you read the book?'. [Ansel:] Yeah, I've read it.
[John:] Did you, what'd you think? [A:] It was alright. [J:] Yeah, yeah, it's a little- it was long in places.
[A:] I loved it, I loved it. [J:] Um, and then, uhh... I think we're about to get hit by a car.
Nightmare scenario! What's your last memory? Ansel Elgort's beautiful hand on my shoulder.
Did you read the book? [Shai:] Yes. [J:] people ask me that all the time, though, like, they think you haven't
read the book. [S:] I read the book. I read the book multiple times. it's definitely one of my favorite books.
[S:] meaning that it's kind of my second favorite- no, not my second favorite [J:]behind
[S:]It's in my, it's in my top two favorite books ever.
[J:] Behind? [S:] I'd have to say that I really love "1984"
We gotta go apparently because somebody is about to make-out.
It's not me. But, I'll see you on friday.
[J:] Ansel, can you say see you on Friday? [A:] See you on Friday, Hank. [S:] Hasta luego amigo!